this
i don't know how to pronounce her name
gloria lamini liebenberg
says my husband and i have introduced
paid menstrually for our female
employees
this makes me so happy as a woman
so some women experience debilitating
menstrual cramps and do indeed find it
difficult to work for some days
each month and
those women i i know i've known some of
them
um do find it um unnerving to
have to request sick days especially on
those on those days
um it's not all women i i really don't
think it's a majority of women and in
fact at a different moment perhaps
we can talk about actually what um
what menstruation and all of you know
all of the things associated with it
mean in light of our post-industrial
context and what it actually looks like
in
in pre-industrial contexts and what
therefore we might be doing to alleviate
um a lot of this um pain and agony for
so many
for so many women who live in the weird
world western
educated industrialized rich democratic
countries
um so it's it's not even close to a
majority of women even in the weird
world
furthermore most women i believe would
prefer privacy
to having a uh a monthly
leave in which um their absence is
therefore understood by
their employer and all of their
colleagues to be about this being that
time of the month for them
this smacks to me of menstrual heights
of for instance the hadza in uh i think
it's west africa
and a few other hunter-gatherer cultures
in which
women are effectively ostracized
while they are um while they're
menstruating and it's a way of publicly
marking them in terms of where they are
in their cycles which is a way for men
to control
um fertility of women and obviously
that's not the
the motivation here it's not the
motivation isn't to control the
fertility of female workers but
um uh it does it feels exactly like that
to me um and um
and you know it'll allow people who are
keeping track to know when
a woman is late maybe when she's
entering menopause when things get
less regular this seems a little less
than desirable for an employer and all
the colleagues to know
so you know if this had emerged from a
conservative obviously this would be
this would be
laughable right it would be just insane
justly ridiculed it would have been
incredible outrage you're gonna do
what now um but um
i think also you know maybe the way to
approach this um as a way to make it
clear that this is just a terrible
policy
and you know and it can't last like it's
just it's no no company that's doing
this is
any company that does this the women are
going to start costing more
and then they're going to start hiring
men more because the women cost more
and then there's going to be complaints
that they aren't hiring enough women and
you know
it's just you know down this road
nothing good will come
um but you know we do have
and i think it's it's necessary that we
have things like pregnancy leave and
there are
real barriers to female success
in career tracks that require you know
hard-paced
hard charging work exactly during your
reproductive years
during which time pregnancy and early
motherhood may
render you less able or less willing to
be hard charging in the same way and so
at least in academia the world that we
know the best
there have been some moves to for
instance stop the tenure clock for a
year or two
such that um you know your public your
publication record
during the time when you were um perhaps
um
perhaps having a kid um does not count
against you in the same way that it
would it's not a perfect solution but
it's
you can't you can't make it the same
right men and women are not
the same and this is you know this is
this will always be a problem there is
no easy solution but i was just thinking
that
um if if time off for for menstruation
is to be a thing given that women
menstruate and men don't yeah you heard
it here first that's
that's actually true um in the name of
equity i think then following this
business is lead it's also true across
cultures across
time that men have shorter life spans
than women
and therefore we should mandate earlier
retirement for men to allow for the same
average period of lifespan that's
post-post-work
um so in order to provide equitable
post-retirement work oh this is such a
dangerous line of thinking because of
course
that limits male earning potential so
you would have to pay them more
to earn the same amount that's true in a
shorter period of time given that our
lives are accelerated um yeah this is
really terrible stuff
it's awful it's ridiculous yeah it's
preposterous and
you know it's another wonderful uh
demonstration of
the need for uh rawlsy and veil of
ignorance
thinking because uh of course if
you know as you uh suggest in here as
you hint at
if it is true that women deserve time
off
uh for um menstrual symptoms and there's
no different
difference between men and women than
men also do
right so the point is you can just see
how if you begin to play with these
conclusions the real point is
here are some people we would like to
give an advantage to and here's some
logic we cobbled together to explain why
they get the advantage
but the problem is it's lego and you
could take those same garbagey arguments
and establish them to prioritize anybody
there are differences
there are differences here's the way
that we can frame these differences
as a burden that needs to be eradicated
or
frankly here's the way so i'm just you
know the insane proposal to allow men to
retire earlier in order to you know
pursue an equitable outcome with regard
to post-retirement years um
is just trying to make the burden you
know
the burden show up in the other column
like we can play this game all we want
right
uh and it's it doesn't make it any more
humane
or reasonable right no and the irony
of it right is if you did play this game
right if you really began to remake
civilization as we are doing based on
these nonsense
uh conclusions that exist in isolation
and you know
steadfastly ignore the thing that would
be on the other side of it if you just
simply uninvented all of the
counter-intuitive
stuff that makes civilization work and
you employed it
you would create all of the failures
that are so intolerable and you would
end up reinventing it on the other side
right i mean if you survive to do it
right the danger is of course
that by hobbling ourselves we don't
exist in a vacuum
and we can't afford to go insane for 20
years
with you know china hovering
outside looking to to poach uh you know
opportunity or whatever um so
we don't get the uh we don't get that
luxury but were we to do it
effectively it would be like a lesson in
why that counter-intuitive stuff is so
important and you know you can almost
imagine the reinvention of all of it and
you know how everybody would suddenly be
aware
of the importance of these things and
really it's like can we just skip to
that part
can we skip to the part where we remind
ourselves why these things are so
important
and why ultimately you cannot do better
than for example
a colorblind society you cannot do
better than a meritocracy in which
people have equal access and i'm not
saying that that's what we have
but i am saying in terms of a goal
that's it yeah you will not exceed it
right so
um yeah we're we've got some system that
has the potential to be functional
and you know how functional it is and
where we are in the process
is what the good faith people are
disagreeing on and we're going to get
push here push there a little bit of
push
um but we are being asked to say nope
we're going all the way over here right
and that's because we've been
all the way over here in the past you
know like in 1950s alabama
and uh before the civil war and you know
all of these things
and you know this kind of arc in society
which we're going from extreme to
extreme
does not leave a society after very many
swings of that pendulum whereas a
relatively tight swing with adjustments
with the ability for constant pushback
against
um a trend towards extremism
on any side can't allow for progress and
history suggests that it doesn't do
exactly that
yeah and you know in some sense you can
reduce the entire thing
to a battle between um
those who wish to fix what's wrong
with the system and all reasonable
people recognize that it doesn't
reach that which it aspires to do but
it's a battle between the people who
want to fix what's wrong
and those who want to uninvent it on the
basis of what is claimed to be wrong
and the fact is the people who want to
uninvent it don't know what they're
talking about
they they can't tell you where we're
headed they can't tell you how we would
get there
and they don't appear to have even the
basic skills to analyze
you know where you need a
counter-intuitive conclusion and we just
don't have time for them to learn it by
destroying what we've got and
having to rediscover it all
[Music]
you